the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
you
okay so up until now in many ways we've
thought about people as individuals
we've you know if how they see how they
remember their personality things you
can measure by IQ tests if they have
psychopathology or not we've primarily
focused on people a sort of individual
agents in the world and for this lecture
for the next lecture we're going to flip
over and think about people as they
interact with other people and here's a
all the way back from 1962 here's a sort
of example and you know so many from
your so much from your life but of how
powerfully we're influenced by other
people and our behaviors is so this is a
story of the rules elevator rules you
guys know elevator rules right you get
an elevator what are you supposed to be
so you don't make other people
uncomfortable or they don't make you
yeah which way you're facing not too
close in space right if there's only two
of you and the other person Huddle's
right next to you go hmm right okay so
anyway here we go
so I was a graduate student in brain and
cognitive science and I got minimally
exposed to social psychology I was
actually a teaching assistant I must
have heard something about it
but it wasn't until I was teaching at
Stanford which is full of famous social
psychologists and I was hearing them
give their introductory psychology
lectures that I got amazed but what
social psychologists have discovered
about human nature and maybe because I
was exposed to in one shot it really
changed for me personally how I try to
think about people from that day forward
so let's see if that does it for you
right and in many ways we're going to do
today the core core famous most famous
things in psychology that the Stanford
Zimbardo Prison Experiment the Milgram
obedience experiment and a theme you'll
see is how funny we are as humans and
our desire to want to fit in so what is
social psychology the scientific study
of the way in which our thoughts
feelings and behaviors are influenced by
the real or imagined presence of other
people so it's how we relate to other
people
and to a certain extent you know if you
compare to things like linguistics or
other or other aspects of psychology it
seemed social things have seemed you
know weakest but people have been
thinking in the last decade more and
more that maybe many things that make
humans humans have been pulled by
powerful social relations that occur in
groups of humans and so for example
looking at cross primate species just
across primates here's the average size
of the social group use their average
size of the neocortex and it's a pretty
good fit and so you can think back in
the course of examples for example the
infant who's willing to crawl across a
dangerous visual cliff if the mother has
a positive facial expression you know
risking injury or worse because you have
a social cue that says it's okay and
you're just an infant interpreting that
so more and more that thought that many
of the abilities we have how we work
together how we communicate together are
driven by our fundamental social
character and so we'll talk today about
the power of the situation this is
what's this is a big idea in social
psychology is that people's behavior can
be phenomenally altered by the situation
they're in
I will talk about attribution how we
decide whether a person behaves because
a certain way because of their character
or the situation they're in the
fundamental attribution error
conformity compliance obedience and
bystanders and I think every there's so
many experiments here that amaze me and
they're still completely relevant today
and I'll convince you that so I think we
engage in all the time as humans is
interpreting the actions and words of
others why did somebody do something
right that fills our lives our families
our teachers our friends or coworkers
why did somebody do something or say
something why is that person looking at
me friendly across the room right so the
causal attribution you know what is
driving that person's thoughts what's in
their mind that's making them to behave
that way and there's at least two kinds
of explanations one of them is character
so personality psychology is all about
that the character of the person is
making them behave that way because
they're outgoing or because they're shy
or whatever so Jeremiah helps the
elderly person across the street because
he's a really nice guy then had a hard
time solving the puzzle because he's
kind of a dummy right so making money to
the boy boy is she nice and generous
right that's the personality
predisposition interpretation so that's
that's the who she is or he is that or
they're behaving that way because
they're in a particular situation so
Jeremiah helped the elderly man across
the street because his friends are
breaking in to the apartment the guy's
leaving behind okay or there's another
person there he's trying to impress that
person what a swell guy he is spending a
hard time solving the puzzle because it
was an impossible puzzle okay you didn't
get a nearly enough sleep the situation
she gave money to the boy because that's
you know he's the drug dealer okay
he went he's a courier running I agree
where it's a situation okay it's a you
know you pick it but you all of a sudden
interpretation completely changes as to
what's going on about character was a
situation so why does the behavior come
from the predispositions of an
individual or the situation they're in
its personality psychologists focus on
this social psychologists focus on this
and they will argue
that this dominates everything this
dominates everything not the only thing
but it dominates everything so let's
consider then in one other way so let's
say that you are late for an appointment
with me so what do I start two things
I'm sitting there waiting for you and
you don't email me you don't call me you
might think well this person's a bit
inconsiderate a bit disorganized a bit
unmotivated it would not be a good idea
for example to show up for a job
interview late for your appointment
right the why because we don't want them
to think we're disorganized and
considered or unmotivated okay until
we're hired so that's the other person
all right like why aren't they here
there's something in here they're
messing up and there's something not
good about their character but imagine
when you're late why are you late
because you're disorganized and
considerate and unmotivated no because
something came up situation right the
traffic was worse than you could have
imagined right last minute it was an
email you know that you had to respond
to or you're a parent call or whatever
some situation made you late and what
I'm going to show you in a moment is
that a very fundamental thing about
people in fact called the fundamental
attribution error is that we're biased
to interpret the actions of others as
revealing their character whereas we're
biased to interpret our own actions as
being driven by the situation we're in
so in all this work we Ross was the one
who came up with this term the
fundamental attribution error the other
person is driven by character we and
that's how we interpret why they do
things we give ourselves a break on the
by the situation and so what they did is
they ran experiments where they wanted
to make it incredibly clear to Stanford
undergraduate research participants
incredibly clear that the situation was
dominant and showed that even then even
when you know for certain is a situation
and you know as much as you can possibly
know you tend to ascribe character to
people okay so they had students run in
pairs and they were truly randomly
flipped it to be a quiz master or a
contestant two students at a time the
quiz master one student comes up with
questions and the contestant has to
answer so they could answer who were the
two inventors of calculus and you know
the answer might be
it's probably you could argue some
things about those right but look you
know this is students it's sort of
unfair that we get to ask you the
question so I get to ask you something
like what's the structure just in front
of the hippocampus that's important for
emotional memory and you might answer oh
no oh no that was on the previous test
it's not cumulative okay and yeah I go
it's the amygdala and I've worked in
that field for thirty years and I feel
pretty proud of knowing that little fact
okay now I need a student hand to go up
okay
now you ask me a question that you think
I might struggle on I believe me hi
there's an infinite number outside the
location of the amygdala pick one from
physics or math or chemistry you're
going to embarrass me but make it really
hard I don't look so bad there's why
sorry a football match this weekend in
England
Manchester No okay I just made that up
okay no I don't know no here's the point
if I ask questions I know the answer
that I picked the question right and you
may or may not know it if you pick if
you create the question you know there's
a pretty good chance I won't know it
right okay so inherently when somebody
beats the quizmaster
they're gonna know the answer and the
other person may or may not know a
pretty good chance they don't as they
make up questions you know that right
logically you know that so the set up
wit and the students were only correct
40% of the time not bad who were
answering the question spontaneously
made up by the randomly selected quiz
master so this is this is experiment
knowing this does it tell you anything
about the knowledge or intelligence
let's call it just a little easy label
of the person asking the questions or
the person answering the questions no
right does that make sense they were
randomly put into positions where one
person gets to ask and one answer yet
even seeing all this right in front of
them then students were asked compared
to the person in general to the average
student is that are the people up there
the quizzer
and the receiver are they less
knowledgeable about average or more
knowledgeable in the average others to
Stanford student and you know in a pure
scientific you sense use to say I have
no idea because you
created a situation when 1% of a
hopeless advantage compared to the other
one right you saw you told me you were
doing that I saw you do that but human
beings can't help but say including a
contestant says you know I guess I'm a
bit dumb but the other person was really
smart the one who knew about the soccer
match in England right and other
questions of it you know or the other
person observing you know that
quizmaster seems to know a lot that
student and this other one the one who's
answering the questions not quite an
average MIT student okay all right yeah
because people can't help but say no
Matt if I see behavior it's because of
the content of your character smarter or
dumber in this case even though I know
logically emote you can remind goes to
that analysis of behavior and others by
their character or disposition here's
another one
participants read essays that were in
favor of Castro who is the leader of
Cuba or gets castro in the US were
mostly against Castro the opinions
expressing assets were presented as
either chosen so the person could choose
to speak what they wanted to speak or
they were assigned by the experimenter
so whereas please give a pro Castro
speech or please give an anti-castro
speech you know that's your job here and
then the people listening said okay how
what's what do they really think about
Castro what do they really think okay
even in a situation where you're told
they're going to be assigned that so
what happens here's how much they
believe that the person of the essay
writer sorry was pro-castro or
anti-castro in the case where they chose
what to do but when they were given the
assignment and now you know it's truly
random it's not quite as much as this
but they still believe that if you write
a pro castro essay even though you're
told the person was assigned that essay
as you read it you go this person seems
to really believe it okay I think
they're really for it because that's
their predisposition you're told fully
this is a situation that's a sign but
humans can't help but think I see
through this a little bit and that essay
is just a little too well-written
a little too convincing for a person
just to be randomly writing it okay so
it's humans even when you give them all
the information that it's a hundred
percent situational they can't help but
interpret things as being built out of
character or predisposition
so people have also thought that this
idea of understanding another person's
behavior in terms of the predispositions
versus the situation that the
disposition of one is made automatically
reflexively that the situation
information sort of follows in a
controlled slow thoughtful way that
takes energy to correct the humans on
the whole first interpret automatically
reflexively the behavior of others as
their character and then second
optionally can correct it thinking about
the situation so the idea is you see
something you immediately apply care you
decide what the person's character is
and then you're maybe maybe we'll slowly
effort fully and consciously think about
what the situation is that led to that
so these are automatic and this is
controlled thoughtful and deliberative
so it may not happen and so the people
to show this it's a slightly complicated
experiment but let me show you how they
wanted to prove that thinking about the
situation demands a lot of extra mental
resources to overcome the initial
interpretation so they had participants
watch silent video clips they said it
was silent because we wanted to preserve
the privacy of the woman who is being
videotaped having a discussion with a
stranger you just see the woman and she
looks extremely anxious on some clips
and not others the task is we want you
to rate how anxious is this person
basically rate your impression about in
terms of their character are they an
anxious type of person some of the
research people who were the subjects
we're told the target was discussing
what the topics were and then they also
did one other thing which some of the
people were asked to just watch and rate
and other people were told not only do
you watch and rate but we're going to
test your memory for the content of what
she said because of that they're trying
to memorize what they hear and the idea
is that you're filling up their
attention with what they're memorizing
they can't make the correction they're
out of mental resources to make the
situational correction so you're
watching these films on anxious topics
or relaxing topics so you know relaxing
topics might be these things tell me
about a foreign film you like or
favorite hobby or speak about your worst
public humiliation a sexual fantasy you
have personal failure who had
and of course these things in red you
could expect a person talking about that
to see more anxious as a personal
anxiety provoking topics okay so so you
so you some of the so here's what
happens so again the topics we they're
anxiety provoking or not and you were
either just watching the film or
memorizing what you were hearing as well
and the hypothesis is that this would
happen
so if you were doing one task and you
were aware that oh this person and you
were told with the topic us has a
relaxing topic or an anxious topic you
could separate out what the task is
versus the person okay but if you were
trying to memorize simultaneously what
the content of the film was that
difference disappears the rating is
identical the people are not taking into
account the topic that's being talked
about because their mind is not because
they're memorizing their mind is
occupied with the content of the scene
and they're not able to sort of correct
the intuitive automatic reflexive
habitual interpretation of a person's
actions based on their character
so in the news today as if it were
organized for our course there's a
fantastic debate about what pictures to
release are not released from what yeah
the the killing of Osama bin Laden a
huge debate going on about whether it
should be released or not that's gotten
the public attention one of the biggest
reasons why among several but a big
reason why there's such a huge debate is
another set of pictures some years ago
from Abu Ghraib prison I'm going to show
you those pictures and the consequences
that were felt to follow from the
release so this is one of the soldiers
who was their private Linda England who
is said to have participated in
maltreating and torturing detainees of
the Abu Ghraib prison so you know when
the United States went into Iraq they
very much had the thought that they were
liberating the country from from tyranny
which in some sense everybody agrees I
think just about they were in some sense
but one of the goals was to convince the
population of Iraq that the United
States was not there to occupy and take
over but to liberate and free the people
of Iraq that was a big message the
United States wanted to send to the
world and to the Iraqis right okay
regardless of whatever else you know or
believe or have political opinion that
was a message the United States wanted
to send to everybody that was huge for
them to do that were there to help free
Iraqi citizens not to occupy and take
over Iraq so imagine when these pictures
came out some of a very large prison
that was run by Americans in Iraq and
these pictures were put on the internet
of various looked like and probably were
served torturous situations here's an
Iraqi person with this hood on their
head with wires connected to the body
here's this that soldier holding a leash
and here's a prisoner on the leash
here's a picture a smiling picture with
her and another soldier here's a pyramid
of naked prisoners piled up went on to
pop the other in a humiliating position
here's another picture of her thumbs up
pointing at hooded naked prisoners
genitals okay and then she was a tried
in court for these things it was
devastating for the NSA these pictures
but
stating the United States because they
were exactly the opposite of the picture
the u.s. wanted to present which is one
of liberation and friendliness and
democracy and freedom and here's you
know tyranny brutality and prison
torture and that's what its figures
hugely in the mind of people in
Washington now's our debating about
these pictures and for the moment they
decided not to release any picture the
power of these pictures as they floated
around to an inflamed and incites
arguments and so here's two ways you can
do it from the viewpoint of social
psychology the disposition attribution
when you mention you're a juror where
she's being tried so you know the
accusing you what she was doing she was
laughing and joking she's enjoying
participating all for her own sick humor
so here's the crime you get angry and
you're not very sympathetic because it's
from controllable factors she should
have controlled herself she's held
responsible she should get a severe
punishment or you could ask and we'll
come back to this at the end of the
lecture nearly on you know were there
uncontrollable factors well beyond what
a person used to reasonably be asked to
control then you're not so angry at them
if you think the situation was very
problematic for example she had a
boyfriend who was the not only superior
to her militarily but also her was the
lingua dode she was a follower she was
an individual was smitten she did
whatever he wanted her to do somewhat
more sympathy person not held
responsible or and the punishment is is
more about rehabilitation than
punishment so those would be two
approaches she was found guilty of one
count of conspiracy and four counts of
now treating detainees one kind of
committing indecent act she was
acquitted in conspiracy count so I'm
going to come back to this in a little
bit after we talked about the stubborn
Stanford Prison Experiment and ask you
your thoughts about this individual from
the information you have so we'll come
back to the a little bit thinking again
about what is a person responsible for
versus with a situation so let's start
to talk about social influence which is
again a change in a person's behavior or
beliefs in response to the intentional
or unintentional influences of others
and we'll talk about three kinds
conformity which is changing your
behavior or beliefs didn't respond to
explicit or implicit pressure from
others that's the person turning in the
elevator compliance changing one's
behavior to avoid conflict
obedience which is following behaved the
demands of more powerful people or
organizations so conformity I mean
conformity sounds like a bad word but we
conform to implicit and explicit social
rules it's pretty useful for social
groups operating if everybody here was
talking and walking in and out and stuff
like that we couldn't talk you know we
have a class right I mean if we didn't
conform in some ways we couldn't do very
much that took more than one person to
do and it's seen across people's and
lifespans and cultures is how in certain
ways we work together as people now the
initial experiment in this came from a
very perceptual effect participants
reported for a study on visual
perception Mushu shared with Sharief
they were seated in a dark room and saw
a point of light appear then move and
then disappear and they were asked to
judge how far the light moved this is
based on a perceptual illusion because
if you stare at a light in a totally
dark room you will start to interpret it
moving even though it does not
physically move you ask me a blacked out
room you have to sit there for a while
and then you start to get signals about
movement they're incorrect and this
perceptual illusion that dot is moving
was called the auto kinetic effect and
that's okay you've seen amazing
illusions and that would be another
amazing illusion of a single dot of
light in a dark room and you start to
think it moves but with the astounding
thing was this here's three individuals
who are tested and their rating of how
much it moved it didn't move so there
are some differences now the three of
them are tested together on day two or
day three and day four and you can see
that these three different people start
to converge on the identical imagined
illusory movement as if the responses of
the others were influencing one and
another on such a simple thing and then
this experiment was made even more
ridiculous by one of the most
spectacular experiments and just in his
simplicity and power and replicability
so for this is from ashe imagine that
you walk into a room and your task is
this now get ready because i'm asked for
a volunteer right now okay thanks
get ready this is going to be pretty
tough okay okay and everybody else will
be nice to you because you volunteered
all right you see this line here which
of these three lines has the same length
number one looks good to you does that
look like a really tough thing no okay
thanks okay I was being a little
facetious all right thank you but you
have to understand this isn't just of
the experiment not such a tough thing
okay pretty obvious here's what they did
you are now you were brought into a room
and there were six Confederates so
that's the word in social psychology
that's used for people who are in on the
experiment okay they're not really
subjects so you walk into a room you
don't know what's going on there's six
other students sitting there and they do
exactly what we did now to show you a
line like this and three other lines and
say you pick it the six other people go
first so you're sitting there I mention
this and imagine the first the first one
says one you go okay and somebody goes
at two hmm all right the next person
says oh yeah - and by the time they get
to you four of the six I said number two
what do you do now to an astounding
extent what you do is this you also say
- okay and it's not like you're saying
I'm just fitting in when they show you
the pictures a few people are turning
their head is there an angle is the
delighting thing you know why do I think
it's number one when everybody else is
pretty for such a simple thing pretty
much so sit you know so the Confederates
are not always wrong but they're pretty
often wrong and in a consistent way it's
all a setup but you as an individual and
here's one of these you see this person
like okay if I look hard enough I'm
going to figure out how did they figure
out that line number one equals line
number two so if you do it by yourself
less than 1% errors obviously the only
error you make is if you're not paying
attention right okay all right with
group pressure not every single time but
all of a sudden 37 times more often you
say it's the wrong line length and
almost always the impression is you
really believe it the people are really
struggling they're really hemming and
hawing okay they're not just this varies
you know not everybody's the same but
only 25% give the correct answer
throughout the experiments 75% of people
at least once will give the obviously
wrong answer because they feel the
conformity is hat you know then
to respond to the other answers given by
the other students around them such a
simple thing as line length we cannot
help but want to fit in and figure out a
way to do that what affects this
conformity well the more Confederates
the more powerful it is that makes sense
right so here's the group size effect so
you know if the only one person is
making it you just figure they're not
too Swift and you can get the line to
people you're already moving up by time
you get to four people you know you're
all the way up there for 4 to 15 is
about the same so for other people
giving you obviously wrong answers you
decide there must be something
interestingly going on and you can
figure it out like they did okay
presence of an ally we'll come back to
this a couple times all it takes is one
person to break the conformity and
you're willing to break that - in these
experiments that set up the Allies and
one of the Confederates who's now told
to give the right length
so one brave person can really change
what you do but it's hard to be that
brave person these allies are set up by
the experimenter so what happens here we
go here's the mistakes being made when
all the other people are saying the long
islands and if one person is giving the
right answers only occasionally still
you do it sometimes but a dramatic
difference from one person giving the
right answer one dissenter opens up your
chance to go with the answer you know
intellectually is correct ah
embarrassment it's amazing the stuff we
all do it's amazing the stuff we all do
to avoid being embarrassed okay
embarrassment is such a powerful thing
for almost all of us there's some
exceptions but for almost all of us so
part of what's going on in conformity is
to not to be embarrassed to be different
and so here's the way they show you that
they have you arrive late you're not
really arriving late they put you know
they tell you oh you should have been
here how we had a miscommunication and
all the other people are here they knew
okay well because you arrived late why
you just write down your answers you
don't have to say them out loud because
you know we can't have you mess up the
experiment now then there's a still not
perfect but people reduced by 1/3
number of their incorrect answers okay
because they don't have to tell other
people what they saw okay it's not
perfect but all of a sudden least that
and a few other things not it Peaks in
ninth grade women on average should have
bit more than men cultures that are more
interdependent showed a bit more than
cultures like the u.s. emphasize
independence but you know these are all
variations on a relatively small thing
fundamentally humans want to conform and
they don't conform superficially that
convince themselves there's something
going on and then the right thing to do
is to conform you know why do we conform
there's all kinds of hypotheses we want
to be right okay
everybody else in that line length I
want to be right I know you know I want
to be popular I don't want be the weird
person not doing this stuff so anyway so
let's come to compliance which is even
more oppositional so you know this from
your life if you have ever spent
something money on something you didn't
mean to because there's an effective
salesperson
it's called a foot in the door technique
and here's an example here's what they
did in 1962 in California Friedman and
Fraser drove two homes random homes show
a large unattractive sign that says
drive carefully then we can all agree
that's pretty non-controversial to drive
carefully and they ask the person knock
on the door and they ask the person will
you place this on your lawn now think of
somebody you know somebody comes up to
you knocks and there it says would you
place this large unattractive sign to
drive carefully and less than 20 percent
say yes okay that's not a shocking
number right they're picking something
that's like you know apple pie right the
mom I mean drive carefully who could be
against that but still who wants a weird
sign on your lawn right okay and they
made it unattractive on purpose all
right ah so 20% here's the other group
they go they sculpture door they knock
on the door and say I have a petition
here you've had that experience on the
street or somewhere here are the
petition in here will you sign up to
support legislation to reduce traffic
accidents okay do you think okay is
there some gimmick here and who can be
again hoots for traffic accidents the
person CEO said please so you okay I'm
going to sign that one right so a lot of
people sign that one then you go back to
that same house a few weeks later and
you ask the sign it moves up to over 50%
so yes for the sign that's the literally
the foot in the door that once you've
signed this petition then you're
incredibly more likely to
yes for the sign and what we understand
that to be as you know through other
experiments we want to be consistent in
our behavior well gee if we're willing
to sign a petition for fewer accidents
why wouldn't we put a sign on our lawn
to further promote you know people not
getting run over okay all right but once
you make the small agreement then you're
willing to do something way larger that
by itself you would never do and I can't
tell you from my own experience how much
that when people end up doing something
they really wish they had done it often
starts and you may know this in yourself
with a small thing
good or bad okay it seems small and need
a little bit more in the new little more
and then all of a sudden you're
surrounded by a SWAT team in your dorm
room right and you said like how did
this happen right you it's amazing how
often things good and bad start with
small steps another small step and all
of a sudden you know you're on a
slippery slope to doing something you
could never have imagined if it would
have been posed as strongly as you ended
up doing it that make sense okay so this
is compliance a little question little
question all of a sudden you're doing
something you would never do by itself
obedience and obedience we think well
you know we're not we're not gonna be
that obedient we you know we to certain
extent they are parents the police our
bosses and firefighters again a certain
amount of obedience I think logically we
think is necessary for social order and
civilization so that we're all organized
in some non chaotic way and in varies
across groups and times and so on but
but we know there are horrible examples
where obedience is associated with
genocide the defense of many Nazis in
Germany was that they were simply
following orders right and in genocides
all over the world tragically tragically
people say there's why do they do that
why would they end up if you opposed it
that way to people why would you end up
murdering you know many people innocent
people defenseless people so often part
of it as being obedient to some group so
now comes when the all-time amazing
experiments that we can't pull off
although I'm going to tell you it was
pulled off in a certain way recently
from Stanley Milgram so it works like
this this is the actual fire that
Milgram at Yale sent out personally
for a study of memory and they'll pay
you four dollars at that time that was
something okay and he would come into
professor stanley milgram the Department
of Psychology at Yale University and
here was the gimmick it was a newspaper
ad like that and you would come in and
there be two people in the room one was
a Confederate and one was you who
naively honestly just shows up to do the
experiment they tell you they're here to
help
science improve learning and memory
through punishment can we improve
learning and memory through punishment
and we're going to say that one of you
will randomly become the teacher and one
will become the learner and they make it
look like a lottery they sort of handed
a piece of paper but it's all a setup
you will become the teacher the other
person will become the learner you will
become the teacher and you get sets of
word pairs to memorize the teacher as a
teacher you give a word and the students
supposed to give you the right answer
you have the answer in front of you and
you tell them whether they were right or
wrong if if you get a if they give you
the correct answer you're supposed to
good or that's right to encourage good
learning if they give you the incorrect
response you're supposed to press a
button that delivers a shock here is the
device they used and with every one of
these buttons the voltage goes up and
you as the teacher sample a 45 volt
shock which I can tell you is moderately
uncomfortable okay alright it's not
terrible but you know it's not fun okay
so you know that in case you had some
illusion about that you know 45 volts is
already pretty uncomfortable so you say
that's how it feels okay okay now the
other person goes into the room and
you're sitting there as the teacher so
here's the setup here you are getting
your four dollars here's the scientist
in a white jacket telling you what to do
the researcher here's the so-called
learner but that's really a Confederate
okay they're not really getting shocked
in the other room but they're going to
play act a lot and you're sitting there
in front of this device that goes from
15 to 450 volts in small steps with 15
volts 30 switches across here 150 has a
label as a strong shock 255 intense 375
dangerous
you're shocked at 435 and 450 there's no
word left for the intensity of shock
they just put xxx all right
initially the learner does well against
a setup the learner knows what they're
supposed to do and but then errors start
to make the learner starts and with
every error you're supposed to go one
worse the learner complains that the
shocks are starting to hurt as they move
up to about a hundred then they scream
in the other room when you give the
shock and the participants I can tell
you they're just like you would think
just like you would do you go like I
really don't like this this doesn't seem
right and the and the person running
experiment says your job is to do the
next thing okay and the people are
suffering and like this can't be right
and how is this happening at Yale and so
much think what you would do the learner
complains about his or her condition in
the other room more errors now the
teacher that is often begging the other
person please listen and pay attention I
don't want to shock anymore do you come
on get it together I don't want to
anymore then the person starts to scream
from the other room you have no right to
keep me here
another shock I refuse to answer anymore
you can hold me here the person shouting
this from the other room my heart is
bothering me at 300 volts the person
says they refuse to answer you turn your
head to the experimenter when you say
the person is not even answering at 300
volts what do I do in the experiment in
this science the scientist and the white
jacket says if there's no response
that's a wrong response so you give
another shock okay and at 350 volts a
person is not even responding anymore as
far as you know they're sort of dead
okay I mean they're not you don't know
what they're doing what you think
something horrible has happened
this is fully play acted and the people
who went through this where´s miserable
summit show that's been almost
impossible to this ever since people
think it's too dangerous for the naive
research participant who thinks they're
nearly shocking somebody to death so how
many people go all the way up in this
person screaming begging saying their
heart is starting to give out and
finally going silence how many people go
all the way up to 450 to all the way up
long after the person has stopped
responding and you get these incredibly
bad
so they asked experts and they said it
would be about 1 to 3% that was a good
way to identify Psychopaths in the world
okay
and you can certainly sit there you can
say what I'm going to say like I would
never do that and I'm going to convince
you in a minute
guaranteed in this room most of you
would do that all the way guaranteed by
any scientific evidence and all of us
will say I would never do that power of
the situation so how many people went
all the way 2/3 went all the way 2/3
look at the round let's see a left into
the year right so yeah if you're three
of you two of you will go all the way
well to tell you I don't know not mean I
mean so here's here's what you know
experts said you know once you get to
some intensity level practically
nobody's going to do it here's the two
thirds of people who went all the way
and even so two thirds went all the way
but everybody went to 100 volts almost
nobody stopped early on ok but 1/3
stopped around 1/3 through 2/3 went all
the way so people have said all this in
1950s people were much more conformist
and obedient okay that was before
Vietnam before rock-and-roll before
Watergate and you know all the stuff
that has made a distrust Authority and
you know before the Internet we know
what's going on all right so you know I
said now come on you guys did it go like
it's not us that's some you know sad
1950s people who are just following
instructions we're independent people of
the 21st century so they almost redid
this experiment in some reduced way a
couple years ago and it doesn't make a
difference
all right so 2009 they well here's what
Houston things they did to get approval
of this first of all they carefully even
more carefully before screen the
subjects to make sure they were in good
mental health they weren't breaking down
people they were told three times they
could stop and still get $50 for
participating okay they were told
multiple times you can stop you can stop
you can stop after the experiment they
were instantly told what the whole thing
was about which wasn't that well
organized before they have a clinical
psychologist sitting there to make sure
that the person seems not too distressed
okay and they said look since we know
that pretty much everybody went to 150
when all the way we'll stop at 150 volts
we won't torture a person all the way
through but 150 is pretty big you're
doing it for quite a bit of time well so
what happens in 2009 for Milgram 79%
went to 150 volts in 2009
70% of undergraduates go to that same
length it looks pretty much the same and
by the way in case you thought women
were more merciful or not they're
identical to men in these studies in
2009 okay it's stunning right and so
everybody who worries about situations
in the world where people do horrible
things to other people is incredibly
impressed by this experiment we're so a
little pressure as a voluntary
experiment where you can stop anytime
and walk out it's not your boss it's not
a general it's not your culture it's not
your you know parents and schools just
an experimenter almost everybody goes
all the way and that's - and 2009 as
well we're incredibly prone if we have
the right situation to be obedient
beyond you know what our humanitarian
spirits suggest it would be so nobody
really knows why we're so obedient
although I'll show you some things that
people have discovered does its status
of the authority figure matter does it
matter that the person seems like a
scientist who knows what he or she is
doing is it belief that the source of
authority you know because they know
what they're doing is must be okay how
much does it matter that you can't quite
figure out how to get out of this
situation and how much it is a slippery
slope like we talked about well if I can
do five volts I can do ten if I can do
ten I can do 20 if I can do twenty I can
do thirty at some house you know five by
five you end up at 400 okay so these are
all ideas so people have looked at this
what if the person gives no instructions
almost nobody does it if the person just
says you know here's the experiment
please do it and it doesn't talk with
you when you say you want to stop people
stop all they have to say though is
please continue and that's enough men
and women aren't different if you do the
experiment not in a psychology here's
the here's the baseline the 70% and go
all the way in an office building it's
less why do you think that people's
interpretation the situation's is not
quite as officially scientific right so
a good lot
if the person in charge doesn't seem
like they know what they're doing
particularly in the white coat does it
seem like an advanced scientist pushes
way back the authority of the person if
the experimenter isn't enough is more
formal but away from you so you don't
see them they're talking to you intercom
or something that pushes you back to do
it less likely the victim is in the same
room as you are that reduces it although
still 40% go all the way if you have to
touch the person while the person's
being shocked that reduces it and if you
have a Confederate who another person
working with you on this who rebels that
also has a huge effect this idea again
if there's one dissenter that frees you
sometimes to follow your own ideas and
thoughts but these one dissenters are
set up you know who who becomes that one
to Center okay
the famous Stanford Prison Experiment
her same idea roughly speaking an
unbelievably relevant to Abu Ghraib it's
almost as if from the viewpoint of
psychologists they had rerun the
Stanford experiment except in Iraq with
real prisoners and American soldiers so
but in the Stanford Prison Experiment
there was a social situate well they
basically told people that they would be
either the prisoners or the guards
Stanford undergraduates and they would
put them in the basement of their
psychology building and they would use
various closets as the pretend cells but
you were assigned to be randomly a guard
or a prisoner to make it a little bit
more realistic they surprised you when
they picked you up you had signed up
okay but they run to your house and the
guy would grab you and say you're coming
now and you're the prisoner okay so
there's a little play acting in this as
well and what they found was that the
guards the Stanford students who were
randomly assigned to the guards became
so sadistic and the Stanford students
who were the prisoners were so stressed
the study was stopped in six days they
were going to do 24 days because people
were sobbing people were doing horrible
things to one another here's pictures of
the this reminds of the Abu Ghraib right
all lined up like that you know typical
Stanford students who were dressed up
and given a baton and they were just
horrible horrible horrible horrible
playing the role of the prison guards
they became abusive and mean to a
astounding degree and so again this idea
now
weirdly enough the only authority here
is this Phil Zimbardo social psychology
and say like your job is to be the guard
and your job is to be the prisoner right
so anybody could have stopped sort of
that anything but once they get playing
these roles vigil it took them only a
few hours to really occupy the life of
the sadistic guard and the life of the
victimized prisoner so think of this
thing in Abu Ghraib where you had a huge
number of prisoners a very small number
of American soldiers very few of the
American soldiers at any training about
how to think about being a guard it was
almost as if you had rerun the Stanford
Prison Experiment add to it fear on both
sides of harm that's intended by the
other groups actuate the cultural
divisions between the Americans and the
Iraqis so they really felt like the
other group was another group I mean you
knew here at Stanford in the basement
but these were your other students right
half the room could be the guards here
half the room could be the prisoners
here nobody has been allowed to rerun
this because the behavior was so
horrible so fast that there's nobody
that you just simply not allowed to do
that experiment like that again and here
again it's a picture of the guards the
students randomly chosen to be the
guards and here's when the students
randomly chosen to be the prisoner it
looks just like Abu grave it's as if you
know the army should have heard about
that experiment before that and here's
more pictures of the sort of abuse and
you can find lots of videos online about
that okay so I'm going to jump forward
to this so again we could think again
the more you know about this you know
how free was this person to do the right
thing and how situationally dominated
were there by Authority and by the
situation that surrounded them if you
think about the Milgram experiment who's
your commander in charge of you if you
think about the Zimbardo experiment you
have the job of being the prisoner of
the guard okay and you know is she
really a bad person or did you put her
in a hopeless situation to do a good job
so um the last thing I want to talk
about let's talk about that for what's
like any thoughts how would you find her
yeah
what kind of abuse was in the prison
well you know from what reads and who
knows how accurate exactly that is you
know they would oh
one person did die not much of it was
the torture of the sort of waterboarding
that you hear about with it was more
scaring the heck out of them and
embarrassing them horribly you know
taking a bunch of people having them all
be naked and piling them up putting them
on a leash okay I'm sure it wasn't
physically nice it wasn't luteal in the
most sense it was more taunting and
humiliating but there was some pain
involved as well it wasn't murderous you
could say that limit you know yeah
it's almost impossible the same thing
with the milkman they did it a little
bit in 2009 with these limitations right
the amazing thing is it looks just like
in everywhere as far as they took it
just like the 1950's Milgram the
Stanford experiment
people now think ethically you can't do
that because not only is the behavior of
the guards abysmal but the people who
were the prisoners were really depressed
afterwards we're really anxious
afterwards
it wasn't like stepping in and out of an
experiment you know as were by the way
the Milgram subjects who went all the
way up they reported being haunted by
this experience for many years to come
so these kinds of things people would
not do now because it's just to consider
too risky for the participants yeah
go on
what's the long-term damage that's a
very good question I don't know if
they've been followed up or that's a
very good question I know for months the
people especially with the prisoners
said they felt very very very bad but I
don't know you know I don't know decades
later they followed them up or not any
that would be an interesting question
yeah
yes I with you it's not so much
psychology I'd say you know I mean give
you my impression I don't have a good
answer its if you get the right kind of
training so you're prepared for a
situation you have much better chance so
remember earlier we talked about now
since very academic compared to these
experiments we talked about cognitive
busyness that if you're if you mind is
not free to evaluate the situation you
interpret in terms of disposition so if
you're you know what does that mean in a
scary complicated situation we go by our
guts okay it our guts are you know the
other person is different I'm in charge
of them as the guard right if we're
trained so that we have a second habit
we can fall back on then we have a
better chance of doing the right thing
when the situation arises is this this
is this is a general point but yeah just
sending in people kind of unprepared
it's not that they have to know
psychology it's that they have to be
told again and again and again when
you're the guard keep in mind that's so
easy to be abusive it's so easy to be
humiliating that you have to guard
against that in yourself that seemed
okay yes it's training we think is it's
not it's not the intellectual knowledge
as practice is practicing so that when
the moment arises you're ready is I
think what people believe is the right
thing okay so the last thing I'm talking
about a couple things is bystanders and
helping and these are just amazing
experiments and in many ways they're all
about embarrassment and how
embarrassment makes us incredibly less
helpful and kind to others than we can
imagine
so the most famous case that began a lot
of this research was the murder in New
York City of kitty Genovese II and I'm
going to read you just a minute about
fur murder
it got a fantastic amount of newspaper
coverage and this was the walk home she
had to her apartment so at approximately
3:20 in the morning of March 13 1960s
for 28 year old Catherine Genovese he
was returning to her home a nice
middle-class area of Queens from her job
as a bar manager she parked her red Fiat
at a nearby parking lot turned off the
lights and started the walk
her second-floor apartment some 35 yards
away she got as far as a streetlight
when a man grabbed her she screamed
lights went on in the 10th floor
apartment building nearby so a lot of
people she yelled oh my god he stabbed
me please help me
windows open in the apartment building a
man's voice shouted let that girl alone
the attacker looked up shrugged and
walked off down the street mr. Genovese
he struggled to her feet lights went
back off in the apartment the attacker
comes immediately back and stabs her
again she again cries out I'm dying I'm
dying again the lights come on and the
windows open in many of the nearby
apartments the assailant again left and
got into his car and drove away she
staggers to her feet as a city bus
drives by it's 3:30 in the morning now
the attacker returns again he finds her
in the doorway at the foot of the stairs
and he stabs her a third time this time
with a fatal consequence it's 3:50 okay
half an hour when the police received
the first call they responded quickly
and within two minutes they were at the
scene she was already dead the only
person with a one person to call was a
neighbor who revealed that he had found
only after a much thought and an early
and phone call to a friend so he doesn't
call the police he calls her friend says
hmm I wonder what I should do here right
who and he said I didn't want to get
involved later was learned there were 37
other witnesses to the stalking and
stabbing over the half hour period why
didn't no one offer any help but call
the police the story in question were
front page news across the country urban
and moral decay apathy indifference were
some of the many offered explanations
this was one of these cases that people
said this shows you how bad off we are
especially in cities where people just
don't care about other people okay they
won't make a phone call to the police
except one person hemming and hawing his
way for half an hour so the lack of the
bystander is helping this woman you know
is it because people are selfish
nowadays you can bet you'd have a video
of that on YouTube right there a
question that was what about the rest of
it and on many of our life fear of
getting hurt what would you have done
now let me tell you the you'll see the
punchline in a moment is the more people
are around who could help the more
certain you are that nobody's going to
help the last thing you want to get help
is a bunch of people okay
the best chance you have is one person
counter-intuitively and against the math
of multiple people so here we go so the
most famous studies and I'll show you
about three of them because they're just
amazing about how we won't help people
because if we not sure what the right
thing to do is and there's other people
there it's too embarrassing to do the
most obvious humanitarian gesture so he
talked that they talked about did a
serious experiments most of them around
Princeton looking at ideas about
pluralistic ignorance let's say each
witness is uncertain whether there's a
real emergency they look around and the
others not reacting this is probably
part of the story decide it must not be
a real emergency social evaluation of
others what are they doing diffusion of
responsibility each person felt that
somebody else is going to get help so
these are parts of the story but here's
the experiments you arrive for an
experiment to discuss personal problems
you signed up here at Princeton
undergraduate you show up there's one to
four people put in different rooms over
intercoms such as one person sometimes
alone or two or two different intercoms
one person the Confederate over the
intercom dramatically enacts a person
having a seizure
alright so imagine you're a student
dramatically VIS randomly another
student starts to say I think I need a
somebody here you know dramatically I
can do it quell enough because there is
I got one of the seizures coming on I
could really use some help if somebody
could help me somebody could help me
choking sounds I'm going to die I'm
going to die choking sound the intercom
goes quiet what do you do well if
there's two of you about 80% of the time
you're going to do something if there's
six of you only thirty percent of time
will anybody do anything yeah
two months ago
to help them
so this is so because you're saying
people can be really selfish to Johns
Hopkins they had an exam and somebody
started having a seizure and neither the
students nor the teaching assistants did
anything to help the person for a long
time okay so you're going to call it
selfish and I'm going to agree in some
sense that's true but I'm going to tell
you it's amazing I didn't hear about the
story it's exactly this thing everything
and I'll show you three more I think
three more examples every experiment
shows that if it's just you and one
person you're incredibly more likely to
help that person and if it's you among
five people or 10 people the more people
the more certain you are to do nothing
and I'm going to tell you in a moment
this is an amazing example why the exam
matters too okay because these
experiments will show you that this is
deeply human unfortunately okay deeply
human and it's not that we're I think
it's not that we're more selfish is that
we're terrible at knowing this is a
question about this we're terrible at
knowing what to do under unusual
circumstances and we're overcome by
wanting to fit in so you know you look
at that person than I do anything they
look at you you're not doing anything
look at that person and you guys are
you're having a faceoff of not doing
anything while the person sort of you
know sinking into their seizure okay and
you could think it's all about
selfishness and not helping but we think
it's something weirdly about humans that
in groups they don't know how to act if
it's unusual they just don't know how to
do it by themselves incredibly more
likely to help so here's an example I'll
show you a couple more where's their
hand yeah this is a percentage of
participants who helped us in the math
are you better off yes this is a
percentage of help you're right then
you're still better off with six but
I'll show you that very often it doesn't
play out that way okay but you're right
you hit you have to do that there's a
trade-off between the sheer number of
people and the likelihood per person
you're absolutely right that varies a
little bit here's another one called
lady in distress a subject walks alone
or with a passive Confederate so the
Confederates set up to do nothing or
with a friend a real friend you come as
a pair and you go into a room that's
separated by a curtain the experimenter
goes to the other room in this case they
made it a woman at the time turns on a
tape recording of a
huge fall much bigger than that boom
okay she's around a curtain okay
and she starts moaning a prerecorded
painful moan you're sitting on the other
side of the curtain who gets up to go
see what happened to the experimenter
who sounds like they had a huge fall and
are moaning with pain this is very much
like example you said almost right okay
what did the people do okay so here's
what happens if you're by yourself
70% chance you'll go there you could
wonder what's happening to the other 30%
but okay that's like it so okay if the
other Confederate if the other person
sits there who's setup to not do
anything practically nobody ever goes it
helps because you're sitting there and
the other person is I'm doing it you're
going on I don't know it's kind of a
weird situation am i invading a person's
privacy maybe that wasn't maybe that
wasn't when I thought it was cuz the
other person doesn't seem to be doing
anything because they're set up if
there's two people who are naive you're
somewhere in between okay so you come
with a friend somewhere in between but
you here's the weird thing the more
people the more you're kind of trying to
figure out what's the right thing to do
and you're not doing anything so I'm not
gonna do anything other person is saying
does that make sense okay every one of
these the more people there are the more
people don't know what to do and they do
nothing because they don't want to do
something weird and embarrassing like
make trouble or not do what you're
supposed to do here's another one where
there's smoke there's fire
subjects filling out surveys smoke
enters through a vent alone you're doing
this survey alone in a group of three or
with two Confederates who notice but
ignore the smoke or our friend you bring
with you
so who leaves the room within six
minutes to go get help when smoke is
billowing into your room yeah all right
now you can say if you sit there again
this is like the moment when you go well
of course I would do it but amazingly
people are sitting there trying to
figure out like should I finish this
first so you know is this really a fire
what's going on here alone 75% of people
get up within six minutes and go tell
somebody there's smoke billowing into
here it was too passive Confederate so
people stop to do nothing only ten
percent of time does the individual get
up and go tell anybody you look around
the other two people are doing anything
you figure well that must be the right
thing to do to naive subjects then the
valid we're doing the math this way
twelve
percent by individuals so a third of the
groups approximately do something okay
that's still pretty low okay
but if you go interestingly in with a
friend that number goes up a person you
really know and trust because what the
interpretation is if it's somebody you
know you're not going to be embarrassed
you can say to that person was a little
wacky but shouldn't we go tell somebody
there's smoke here or somebody collapse
next door and they're the friend goes
yeah it's probably a good idea I don't
know but maybe we should do that right
but if you don't know the person you're
not going to have that conversation so a
friend is very powerful to release you
from this but if you don't know the
other people you yeah I don't know that
they've done this so these are usually
done with undergraduates so then just
you just bring your roommate or your a
pal okay yeah I don't know if it matters
at other levels so that's a very good
question maybe people have looked at I
just don't know this is the last
experiment okay and this is kind of the
topper of all of this and this gets back
to being an exam situation I'm glad you
brought up either because it's this is
almost an ironic experiment in a deepest
sense since again Turley at Princeton
the good samaritan so what's the story
of the Good Samaritan from the Bible for
those who yeah
somebody really injured on this road up
side of the road right
he's from Sumeria okay I'm just telling
this you know Isaac yeah yeah now I'm
going to tell you one more thing and
which is Sumerians we're not the most
affluent members of society of the time
this matters for the story in a way
you're about to hear okay so good
Samaritan so they took students now
think about this this is because they
want to show you how absurdly weird it
is when it is we're willing to step
forward and help a person I don't think
it's about goodness it's about the
weirdness of our minds and not
embarrassing ourselves and how
preoccupied we are with our other
business okay so so social psychology
are going to tell you the reason the
good samaritan stop was not because he
was such a good guy it's because he
didn't have so much to do okay and
here's the experiment they're going to
tell you why okay it's very so these are
students these are seminary students
studying to become ministers okay so
this is this is the group they pick this
group because they want to show you
social psychologists get irritated by
personality psychologists they say can
you pick a nicer group than people
studying to be ministers okay that's the
pre dismiss is disposition okay and
there are they're filling out surveys
about religious values in a room they're
told that they're going to have to
present a talk about the set about
either seminary jobs or so this is
career ism or a sermon on the good
samaritan that's the best one okay so
you're sitting there going help people
help people help people help people cuz
this okay all right all right their
practice their speech they're prepared
okay
then they're released to go give this
talk in front of other faculty members
and their students so they want to do a
good job either they're sent to the
building across the campus ahead of time
plenty of time on time they have or
they're late to go oh my gosh you didn't
go over we've told you should be all
you're gonna be if you don't run you're
gonna be late okay you don't want to be
late to give your practice sermon or
speech to the faculty committee waiting
for you right now as they pay and then
here's one more thing to keep in mind
some of you probably have visited
Princeton New Jersey just to give you a
sense of this this is even back in the
1960s but even now have so who's been to
Princeton New Jersey you know Princeton
University yeah you have okay
scary urban environment full of
threatening noises the campus itself
pastoral place full of eating clubs and
references to F scott Fitzgerald and I'm
just adding in that Princeton is a
pretty non-threatening
place the campus itself I'm just I'm
just adding this in because you got to
keep this in okay that here's the
Confederate it's a man slumped in a
doorway moaning in obvious pain hunched
over on the ground okay now on the path
to giving the speech who stops to help
anything that could measure about the
personality this individuals made no
difference whether you stopped to help
whether you are saying stop to help stop
to help stop to help because you're
going to give a talk about the Good
Samaritan or going to talk about career
paths okay
doesn't make any difference at all so
amazingly the people zooming by the
centric person are saying stop and help
the person stop you know the guys
moaning and the in a doorway next to
them and as a walking story is in the
next times they go okay what counts as
to who stops they're by themselves it's
not a group thing now they're by
themselves right it's if they're ahead
of time if they have time because they
know they could stop it help somebody
and still make their talk on time
63% stop forty five if it's going to be
a close call ten percent if they're
rushing because they're going to be late
okay this is you know so this so they're
taking the exam it says the description
you set up a big group of people taking
an exam they're like this like they're
pressure they're pressure they're
pressure okay and there's a lot of us
somebody's going to take care of this if
they need to and I've got I've got
things to do you know like take an exam
or run over and explain how incredibly
important it is morally to help those
who are injured and around you right so
it can't have a more sort of a
you know literary experiment showing you
how weird it is when we stop and help
people yeah first I stop next person and
ask other feet their self excellency
so eventually we call the police will be
responsible so keep it going by
that's Gopi said okay so you're getting
a story in real life on the campus here
what two feet were sticking out from a
bush all right no no no this isn't me
this is this is not a setup okay you're
not a Confederate okay yeah yeah so
first you want to have somebody else no
but this is really interesting I mean
yeah yeah because that's the first thing
right like yeah we what do you think
good idea to have a body here bad idea
of about of here and another person
walks by and say what we like your
opinion before we do anything that
person says I can't stop there's that
you know I have things to do right I
have homework yeah
it's astounding so oh you know that I'll
just stop is saying it makes you think
you use the word selfish and and
definitely I don't mean to pick on you
it's just weird how humans are like this
you know you see this all the time for
me personally the final attribute
these things have really changed how I
interpret situations and and you know
how much I think a person is a crummy
person because up until the fundamental
attribution error although I always gave
myself every break for doing everything
wrong okay I always interpreted other
people's failings as like deep character
flaws right and it has made me you know
personally stop and think if somebody is
not doing something I wish they did or I
think would be better maybe from their
perspective they're in a situation
that's drug compelling them to perform
less well than I think they should or
something like that so these are
unbelievably fascinating things and very
convincing and it's very sad you know
when they set up prisons not remembering
these lessons that are so clear-cut and
I think the huge thing to know about
this as far as we possibly understand
this is true of everybody you know all
of us none of us think we would do this
all of us are prone to do this through
many many many experiments without any
evidence to the contrary from a
scientific viewpoint it's about as
convincing a story as you can possibly
have all right thanks very much
you